so we will be starting
in another
few minutes and we are also going live
on youtube
so if you know that you want to watch on
youtube you can also do that
and you can find us on youtube uh with
our channel name which goes by
pine biotech so that's the name of our
channel
and you can subscribe to the channel as
well we keep on sharing and posting
about different
resources
and other related resources about
multi-umx
and ngs on our youtube channel
and thank you
banu rajendran for sharing about
yourself
in the chat box you can also leave your
emails in the chat box if you want us to
reach out to you regarding any queries
or if you have your own query and you
can always email us at marketing at
find.bio
for your other queries
yes hi vishnu yes we will be sharing the
recording as well with you
once the session is over
if you are already registered then you
will be receiving the recording of the
session
or you can also watch it on youtube and
it
is also going to be streamed live so
this will be the youtube link
yeah thank you
hello everyone and welcome back to the
first
session of omics logic introduction to
bioinformatics program this program
is an introduction to the field of
bioinformatics or the intersection of
bioinformatics
and biology in this program
we will discuss the changing landscape
of data driven research in life sciences
and the opportunities that come with the
widely
accessible high throughput technologies
and computational methods for analysis
and annotation of such detailed data
in research and industry we will discuss
various emerging technologies and their
impact on
health care agriculture environmental
sciences
public health and more
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
that are part of our bioinformatics
community
managed by pine biotech let me start by
introducing pine biotech the company
behind omics logic
share with you details about the
upcoming omics logic programs and
explain
how life training resources will be used
in the introduction to bioinfomatrix
program
over the course of the past several
years
our team has been collaborating with a
number of academic institutions
around the world that have participated
in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
as a result the omics logic programs
have been thoroughly evaluated
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes
importantly the programs are designed to
support
students with minimal bioinformatics
background including
biology and biomedical studies majors as
well as faculty
interested in bioinformatics data
science
and biomedical research the goal of the
omics logic programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and pure example developing a
growing community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology in
life and data sciences
in six interactive sessions you will get
to see
the broad applications of next
generation sequencing
biostatistics and tool for big data
analysis
in practical assignment we will be
learning about the logic of bipho matrix
and see how
data science methods can be used to
study biology
in conclusion you will also be able to
plan
how to take what you have learned and
apply them to an independent research
project using tools and methods we cover
in the program so this is the schedule
for the six sessions that are going to
be part of this one month program
and we will be discussing them in more
details
and now let me introduce you to the main
speakers of today's session and the
mentors
of this one month program
we have elia brodsky our
pine biotech co-founder and ceo in his
current role he has
extensive experience working together
with
industry and academic partners that are
applying
multi-omics integration and
bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications dr harpreet
kaur
is a certified omix logic trainer and
expert bioinformatician who will guide
the hands-on sessions and
assist the participants with projects
and analysis
during the program her area of
specialization is cancer genomics and
machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is a romix logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology and over 10 years of experience
working with
industry and academia and now
i would like to pass it on to ilia to
take over the session
thank you everybody
thank you and uh welcome everyone to
this first session
that will be focused on the very basic
introduction so we'll talk
today about processing and analysis of
high throughput data sets and some of
the logic behind
analysis pipelines we'll also discuss
some of the resources that you have
access to
in this program and how you can combine
the logic of bioinformatics with
practical skills
that are needed to succeed and excel in
big data analysis
my name is elia brodsky i'm the
co-founder and ceo of pine biotech and
i'm excited to join you today
for this short program the program is
just
a first step and it's designed for
biologists
biology students for those that are in
clinical research in biomedical research
but also those that are interested in
other aspects of next generation
sequencing
and big data in life sciences
so why so many of us are actually so
interested
in bioinformatics and data science
the truth is that biology is acquiring
the character of a data science
so many experiments are producing large
volumes
of heterogeneous information that needs
to be
analyzed processed and integrated
to lead to insights and discoveries and
so the goal of the omics logic programs
is to introduce biology as a data
science preparing biologists and
clinicians
for this influx of data that will only
continue to grow
and also helping them master the
associated methodologies
of data-driven research by focusing on
projects and understanding how
bioinformatics can
help us overcome the challenges of
discovery
and experimental design as we think
about
different aspects of life science
research
and industry so in this session i will
introduce
some of the topics that we're going to
be covering i'll talk a little bit about
the basic bioinformatic approach to big
data by showing you how to run
and analyze outputs from different
pipelines
we'll talk about different types of
omics data because there's a variety of
different
information that they can provide
and we'll also talk about some of the
resources that you can leverage
in an asynchronous way after this
session
and during this whole program so the
course
that we're discussing here this program
and today's session
is really designed for those that come
from a non-engineering background
to introduce bioinformatics for students
biologists and clinicians
and understand how you can personally
get started
with your bioinformatics research
journey
so one of the important things that we
have to recognize
is that the influx of data
is continuously increasing in speed
variety and volume all the way back
from the 1950s when the genome was first
when the human genome was assembled up
until today
there have been new technologies like
next generation sequencing
that have produced continuously growing
volumes of data of different types and
have been made
publicly accessible and one of the
primary examples of that
is the national center for biotechnology
information
the national center for biotechnology
information contains
different types of repositories and one
of them is the gene expression
omnibus or geo which by itself
contains over 80 000 publicly available
data sets that include
gene expression profiles of hundreds of
tissue types
in thousands of organisms across a
variety of different types of conditions
so we really see how the available data
opens up the door for those of us
interested in
handling these data sets and designing
hypotheses
driven by data that is already there
to be able to access high quality data
sets
that were produced by cutting edge
labs and in amazing projects that we can
all
learn from and leverage for our own
study and research
and that's what this program is going to
help you do we'll actually go
on ncbi geo sra
jam bank and other repositories find
project data analyze that data together
and discuss the results the different
inputs and outputs
of technical pipelines but also
conceptually we'll be able to look at
the different
types of analysis methods that are
applied to different types
of data so what kind of data
are we going to be talking about we are
going to be focusing
on biomedical research as an example
but you will also be able to apply this
to agriculture
biotechnology and basic life science
research
however in the field of biomedical
research
it's important to understand the
critical role that biomarkers
play in the diagnostic process
helping clinicians make day-to-day
decisions about their patients
including characterizing the disease
identifying the stage of disease
progression and selecting therapeutics
this is based on the work of researchers
that can produce high throughput data of
different types
to study what happens at the subcellular
subcellular level and importantly to
integrate that
with all kinds of additional data sets
and repositories that exist
to describe the condition from a
clinical perspective
as well as to identify the specific
interactions
between proteins pathogens and hosts
as well as the different types of
processes that happen
inside the cell so this program is
designed to highlight
the role of large omics data sets
or big data that is shaping modern
biomedical innovation
where molecular data is used for
precision diagnostics
big data integration and machine
learning are transforming
personalization of treatment selection
and innovative algorithms allow for
unprecedented capabilities
with drug discovery design of molecules
and drug repurposing so hopefully
we will start talking about all of these
topics today
but before we do let me ask you a few
questions so first of all
what are some examples of omics data
that is used in research that you know
of okay so you can use the chat box
just write your answers and later on
we'll be using your responses
to continue and speak about different
aspects of the program
so what kinds of omics data
are you familiar with but we have
proteomics and genomics
joshua stephen is saying proteomics
okay we have sharma saying metabolomics
genomics transcriptomics excellent so a
lot of you
are familiar with the term omics
and for those of you that are putting in
answers like sra
or other types of answers really
the question here is sra is
a repository it's a database but here
we're just
talking about the different types of
onyx interactomics okay so it's very
interesting to consider
how many different types of omics are
going to be listed here so that's really
the point of this question so thank you
for answering this question
let me ask you another question related
to this
what kind of information can we learn
from transcriptomic data
so genova is saying gene expression
sequences differential gene expression
mrna
rna detail interactions mrna
gene genetic expression
excellent so let's think about
transcriptomic data so transcriptomic
is one type of data that you all
correctly identified it speaks about the
rna
mrna different types of small
rnas like micrornas long non-coding rnas
so transcriptomic is everything that is
being
transcribed so everything that is being
expressed
now studying gene expression data
we can look at levels of gene expression
and compare them between different types
of conditions
so that's called differential gene
expression we can look for
profiles of gene expression across a
variety
of classes of conditions or samples
we can also talk about transcripts or
isoforms
how genes can be alternatively spliced
in the process of transcription
and identify differences in alternative
splicing
between different conditions and
obviously
depending on the data preparation
protocol
we can also explore other types of rna
that is being expressed
so i think it's important to understand
that we have multiple types of omics
data
and each type of omics data can provide
us with
different types of information let me
ask you
another and final question for now
what are some of the challenges that you
know of with
analysis of omics data
ishwarya is suggesting accuracy
mutation data redundancy not much
exposure
precision false positive
repeated unwanted expression
errors size
missing out on some data
data type and accuracy overlapping okay
so
there are some interesting challenges
that are being mentioned right now
in the chat box and let's briefly
summarize what is being said
so one aspect is technical technical
just the size of each data set for
example when we talk about
transcriptomic data
we talk about gigabytes or hundreds of
megabytes per sample
the bigger the sample set maybe tens or
hundreds of samples
very easily we can see how our computers
are going to run out of space
and run out of computational power
now the other side of it is just the
ability to annotate
so when we have a reference genome or
the transcriptome
when we have the reference genes and
their annotation
there's a lot that has to happen before
we can interpret with confidence and
therefore a large part
of part of the analysis is being able to
identify
the correct annotation databases the
right
references and link all that information
together
that the identified results could be
tested biologically
now it's also important what is
described here is that we're dealing
with
real biological samples so samples that
are being studied
in india or in china or in the us might
be prepared in different ways
sequenced at different time points using
different machines so there is
a large variability between the quality
and the specific biological conditions
that are being provided in a way that we
are
used to deal with data which is more
standardized
right when we speak about other types of
data for example measurement of weight
or height or even clinical abbreviations
for different
conditions and indicators we're used to
everything being standardized and here
when we're talking about biological data
and this high throughput data that
speaks about
individual processes within the cell
at a molecular precision we are going to
be facing this additional challenge of a
lot of technical noise and a lot of
biological variation so that's
what we will try to address in this
program
the program is going to talk about
data-driven research in this age of high
throughput data in life sciences so
we'll look at a lot of these different
challenges that we talked about just now
we'll talk about the reference genomes
and how additional references and
changes to the reference genome and its
annotation can help us
understand what is really going on we'll
talk about different computer languages
coding languages and operations that can
help us find
patterns in data and we'll learn about
effectively
launching different functions and
different analysis
algorithms to extract meaningful
information
and we'll also talk about this big
challenge of integration
of various biological data so that it
can be used
effectively in research as well as in
industry applications
like in pharmaceutical industry and
biotechnology
so to do that we'll talk about different
aspects
of the way the data is generated
the way it could be analyzed from a
statistical perspective
and the way we can account for different
types of variations in experimental
design
so that when we are coming to
conclusions we can
go back and retrieve all the steps and
make sure
that the analysis is robust and
reproducible now many of these things
are going to be applicable
universally to any types of omics data
but as you probably will soon discover
handling everything at the same time
is going to become overwhelming so we'll
focus on
several examples and instead of speaking
about theoretical approaches
we'll try to go deeper into projects and
really see
how such analysis decisions can impact
the results
in the context of very specific examples
i'll speak more about the different
project examples in just a few minutes
but before that i want to introduce you
to a place where
anyone can start learning about
bioinformatics
so let's go to a course called
introduction
to bioinformatics
introduction to bioinformatics is a
course
that is available for free on our
educational portal
so beeps have pasted a link in the chat
to access this course you have to
register
and log in for those of you that are
part of the program you should already
be logged in and i suspect that many of
you have already
looked at this uh specific
course so once you get to this course
sorry once you get to this course you
will see the introduction
to bioinformatics please put in number
one
in the chat box if you have reached this
page
this specific course is free and i will
speak about
some additional free courses in just a
second
and i will also speak about some
additional courses that we will leverage
in this program and they are packaged
within the program registration price
all right excellent so as you reach this
page again some of you might have
already started on this course
previously
but i want to briefly show you what
these courses
offer and how to best utilize them to
start with bioinformatics so this course
provides an overview of big data
in different applications of
bioinformatics
and okay so for those of you that are
here please make sure that you are
logged in
once you are logged in you can log in
with your email address
or you can register with your social
media
you will be requested to complete your
profile
and you will also be able to change your
password once you have completed the
registration
so once you're here you click on take
the course
and that's the way to get started now
this is a free course so anyone can get
started with it
and let's just take a look at what this
includes
so if you click on the curriculum tab
you will see that one of the first
things
is a survey and so the goal of this
educational portal is not only to allow
you to learn about bioinformatics and
start practicing applying bioinformatics
to different data sets
but also for us to learn more about you
and connect with you so that we can
identify
the most efficient way to help you at
the place where you
are now after you have registered you
will have access
to the intro survey which we ask you to
complete
so that we can learn more about your
location your level of education
and the organization that you belong to
after you complete that you will be able
to see some examples
that show the data-driven discovery
paradigm shift
real-life examples in healthcare and
other types of applications of
bioinformatics including environmental
science
agriculture defense public health and
others
now after we go through some of these
topics we will also discuss
how to build bioinformatics pipelines
and we'll use
the t-biome for platform to illustrate
and do a demo together so that everyone
understands how to get started with
bioinformatics
and data sets like genomics and
transcriptomics
[Music]
so as i mentioned this course includes
a survey and in the survey we're going
to be getting this information
reviewing it and getting back to you and
we will
also ask you to evaluate the content
what we've seen
is that both students and faculty find
this course informative and learn a lot
from
the variety of types of applications
that bioinformatics has
and the critical importance for
biologists
and others engaged in life science
research
now this course is going to talk about
the
emergence of big data that changes
everything it will show you some experts
that speak about their understanding of
bioinformatics
and the way that they affect healthcare
today
it will also help you learn the
terminology
and talk about different types of omics
data
and evaluate your understanding using
a quiz so here's an example of that quiz
now in addition to this free course we
also have a number of
other free courses on genomics
and metagenomics and all of them will be
introduction too so you will see
introduction to genomics
introduction to metagenomics so anyone
that is
learning about bioinformatics for the
first time
or is joining this program for the first
time we encourage you
to take some time to explore some of
these free resources
and start to really understand how you
can get
started in this journey of
bioinformatics
now in addition to these free resources
we are going to be leveraging some
additional coursework
that we have on this portal and what's
important about this portal
is that we are going to discuss how the
theoretical material that is being
discussed
could then be converted to a practical
application of bioinformatics so for
example
in each one of these courses on
transcriptomics
we are going to discuss the process of
generating rna-seq data
analysis of rna-seq data for processing
where we get a table
of uh when we have a table of expression
then you will get an introduction to
statistical analysis
of rna-seq data analysis
of rna-seq data using machine learning
and data mining
and finally an introduction to single
cell transcriptonics
we will then continue on to explore
genomics
starting from introduction to genomics
variant calling in genomics 1 and
downstream analysis of variants
in genomics 2. we'll also explore
a variety of courses on epigenetics or
epigenomics
epigenomic data describes different
types of
dna methylation patterns as well as
histone modification
that can help us understand non-dna
encoded regulation of gene
expression importantly we will also
touch on metagenomics
when we talk about metagenomics we can
study a
thousand of different microorganisms or
millions of microorganisms that live in
communities that
function and work together to affect
every aspect of our life
from immune responses to responses to
different treatments
and also the interaction between the
microbiome
and the different types of pathogens
so we'll talk about all of these
different aspects of different types of
omics data
importantly every course that you
complete comes
with a certificate of completion so
those of you that are looking to get a
certificate
instead of joining the webinar and
looking for a certificate
you will be able to complete that course
passing the quizzes
and assignments and then you will be
getting
the certificate of completion for that
particular course
now once you get to that end it's
important that the certificate will be
generated
for your profile and so you have to make
sure that your profile
is complete in addition to some of these
resources
we will also talk about the practical
application of bioinformatics analysis
so you will see
bio data science is a selection of
courses
that introduce you to important types of
analyses
using r and python and you can also
explore
an additional portal that we will
utilize
during this the the next few sessions
called code.omicslogic.com
so i'll talk about that in a few minutes
but for those of you that are having
trouble
with the educational portal i invite you
to go to
code.comicslogic.com also
a website where you can register for
free and start exploring
some of the same analyses using coding
in
r and python the way these
courses are organized is they provide
with a clear outline of what you might
expect from
joining a course understanding the
terminology the biological context the
different data formats
and understanding and analysis logic
you will also have topic mapping by
engaging activities where you will
understand how the different theoretical
aspects
of bioinformatics are applied directly
to the different data sets and in what
order and why
then you will be able to understand how
these apply to a very specific
data set or project so you'll be really
able to see project examples taken from
research publications and known
databases
that actually show you the specific file
formats in the context of a biological
question finally
you will be able to deploy an analysis
pipeline and the way that the courses
are built
is first of all you learn about them you
practice with a demo
and once you've mastered the practice
you can start applying this
to independent projects that you can do
on your own
so after you get a certificate of
completion of at least several courses
that are free
or that are included with this program
you will be able to access
the practical analysis that is offered
on the t-balance platform
but you don't just start with analyzing
data without first understanding how to
apply it to a very specific project so
that's why
we will also talk about a variety of
different project
examples now in this program the
introduction to bioinformatics
for biologists we will take a few of
these examples
that are sourced from peer-reviewed
journals
in in high-impact biomedical journals
for example we will use modeling cancer
precision
medicine one of these projects is taken
from a publication
that was that was published in
in genome biology called modeling
precision treatment of breast cancer
and it was published by a company called
genentech
so this is a pharmaceutical company that
invests heavily
in applying bioinformatics and machine
learning to
large transcriptomic genomic epigenomic
and proteomic datasets
to understand how different drugs
interact and affect
different types of tumors in cancer
biology
in this particular study the authors
explored
the different omics data sets and how
they could help predict
the effect of different types of
therapeutic
molecules that range from the standard
chemotherapy
to more advanced immune
immunological drugs so to speak a little
bit more
about how bioinformatics is used in
cancer
research i want to invite dr harpreet
kaur
she is going to be participating in this
program
to help those of you that are interested
in learning about bioinformatics
and will share from her experience being
an
expert in cancer genomics harpreet
could you please share a little bit
about your background
thank you so just let me know
if you could please speak up
let me just share my slides
so hello everyone my name is harvey kaur
i have a phd in bioinformatics my
research is on biomarker discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
so what inspired me to study liver
cancer is the high mortality rate of
this malignancy
and a lack of precise biomarker that can
help
diagnose liver cancer at an early stage
it is sixth major cancer in terms of
incidences
worldwide and fourth in terms of
mortality
liver cancer is often at times
misdiagnosed
or detected too late for an effective
treatment
another factor that contributes to its
poor
outcome for the liver cancer patient is
the frequent reoccurrence of
this particular tumor so with these
concerns
in mind i frame a number of research
objectives
with my collaborators to address these
issues
using bioinformatics
for the first part of this research
project
we used last scale transcriptomics data
to identify a diagnostic biomarker panel
for hepatocellular carcinoma which is
primary liver malignancy so in this
study
we employed 30 data sets containing
nearly 4000 samples to lucid day
transcriptomics biomarker panel
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
implementing multiple statistical
and bioinformatics techniques
for the next part of this research
project we use transcriptomics
and methylation data to identify
biomarker panel
for stage classification of
hepatocellular carcinoma here
we employ tcga data set of 350 samples
and elicited 51 features
that include 30 rna transcripts
21 methylation cpg size using
number of data mining approaches
the navy's model classified early and
late stay samples
of hepatocellular carcinoma with nearly
79 percent accuracy
for the third part of this research
process
we use transcriptomics data to
scrutinize
diagnostic biomarker parallels for
chlangiocarcinoma
which is another major liver malignancy
so in this study we employed nine data
sets
containing 350 clengio carcinoma
133 adjacent non-tumor
and 90 hepatocellular carcinoma sample
two secretinized clencho carcinomas
specific
transcriptomic signatures and here we
have employed a number of data mining
techniques
like extra tree svm random forest
logistic regression lda etc
so in conclusion we have
identified a universal platform
independent
three gene based biomarker that can
protect
scc patients with high precision
and also possess a significant
prognostic
tension then we identified a three
gene-based glandular carcinoma specific
transcriptomic signature
that are capable to discriminate cca
from scc and the normal samples
at last we identified a wire marker
panel
of 51 features that include 30 rna
transcript
21 methylation cpt site to predict the
hepatocellular carcinoma
at an early stage
so i am looking forward to vn your
mantle during
this introduction to the bioinformatics
program
and help all of you to learn about data
analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application to large data sets
used in biomedical research
in this program i will be speaking about
the role of big data
that plays in biomedical research that
can generate a hypothesis
that is then analyzed and used for
accuracy improvement
and what this process is affecting
clinical cure
now i would like pass this session back
to ilia
so over to you
thank you harpreet and let's address
some of these questions
that are coming up in the chat as we
move on
so what's important about what we're
doing today
is this is just the first session in
this session we're giving you an
overview of what we will cover in
greater detail
in six additional sessions in the
introduction to bioinformatics program
we will also introduce slowly step by
step the different types of analyses and
the different types of project examples
so we will actually have experts like dr
harpreet kaur
and dr mohit mazumder who will be
speaking in a moment
help you identify data sets extract them
from
publicly available repositories like
ncbi
and run analysis that will help you
identify
biomarkers just like harpridka or just
explained so that you can try and do
this
on your own now in her research they
focused on
liver hepatocellular carcinoma which is
a particular type of
liver cells that lead to cancer
so we will go through different types of
cancers like
breast cancer lung cancer liver cancer
and you will be able to see how the same
types of principles
could be used to work with clinical and
omics data
this program is just an introduction and
after a few more slides after we
introduce you to the practical tools
that we will be utilizing
you will also hear from dr mohit
mizunder about research projects
developed by previous participants of
the omixlogic training programs
that you will be able to follow and do
the same
as you make use of these different
practical resources
that we will be describing in a second
does anyone else have any questions
before we move on
okay so for those of you that would like
to still complete the registration
thank you for posting your email
addresses beeps that will be
emailing everyone details on how to make
sure that your registration
is complete and you're welcome to email
marketing
at pine.bio with any types of questions
that you might have
about registration or links that are not
opening
okay so let's continue speaking about
some aspects
of the program that will help you make
more use of bioinformatics and apply
clinical thinking to applying
bioinformatics different types of data
sets
okay and also for those of you that
are interested in cancer biology i think
bioinformatics has shown
a lot of promise in cancer biology and
we'll talk about a lot of different
examples
that will help you understand how these
methods work in real clinical
settings as well
okay thank you harpreet all right so
uh what's important as you join the
program
is to make sure that you complete your
profile so each one of you gets a
personal profile so for those of you
that are interested
in doing more with this the interaction
during the session
is really to help you understand some
basics
but the work starts when you start
practicing
so this is not going to be interactive
in the sense that
you know 100 people can all talk at the
same time that i don't think is going to
be very useful
but what will be useful is when you
start applying
the methods that you learn to specific
data sets and we start interacting with
you
around the analysis challenges that you
might have to clarify
how to apply these tools effectively so
the first step is to really
complete your profile as you work
through the different coursework you
will receive
assignments and those assignments
include analyzing data
which includes running some
bioinformatics pipelines
you will also see that a lot of the
courses have quizzes
and those quizzes are tracked so that we
can understand
where you are failing and try to make
sure that we understand and you
understand all of the concepts that are
being
covered and we also track your progress
over time
making sure that you are actively
participating and benefiting from the
different resources that we have
made available at the end of that
process
when everything is finalized and you
have gone through the different
coursework and started working on an
independent project
you will receive a certificate the
certificate could be a certificate of
completion
or a certificate of excellence
so for those of you that want to
distinguish yourselves
and really showcase the ability to
analyze data
the more you do the more it will come up
in your profile for example
in this profile you can see that sarah
zapiko who is
a faculty at university of florida has
reached over
18 000 points so anyone who reaches more
than 10 000 points will be able to get
a certificate of excellence and also for
those of you that complete an
independent project
will also get a certificate of
excellence now let me introduce you
briefly to some of the other practical
resources that we will leverage
during this program
this is another important part of what
we will do
actually applying big data analysis
to these data sets that we describe
about cancer
and other types of conditions so please
go with me
to the server that t bio dot
info okay so maybe
put in number one in the chat as you
reach
this link server that t dash bio data
info
when you join this program you will get
a personal
account on this big data analysis
platform
for those of you that are joining today
as observers
you will be able to use a demo account
so beeps if you could share just the
first demo account details
with those that are joining us today
okay so those of you that already have
completed your registration
you should have gotten an email with
your personal account
your personal account contributes points
towards your own
account uh progress and for those of you
that do not have an account yet have not
completed your registration you can use
this demo account for now so again i see
that
one person has reached the server has
anyone else
reached this server and used the demo
account
okay great so we have a few more please
let me know i will
give it a pause just a couple of minutes
until everyone
reaches so this is the
t-bioinfo platform it is a big data
platform developed by the tower
bioinformatics research center
this is a research center at the
university of haifa
focused on development of novel
algorithmic approaches
to big data analysis specifically in
application to omix data
you will find that this specific page
demonstrates the different areas of
analysis including
next generation sequencing data mass
spectroscopy
structural biology and tools for data
integration
and modeling so what we will do today
is look at one example of a
bioinformatics pipeline
related to transcriptomic
transcriptomics so please open this
arrow
and go with me into this demo for
rna-seq data
once you're here click on start
and you will see that each button
represents
an educational resource where you can
learn about the typical steps
to process or prepare sequencing data
for downstream analysis the first step
is to clean up the reeds next generation
sequencing produces
shotgun sequences which means that they
are taken from random places
in all of the material that has been
shattered and
are sequenced in short reads these reeds
could range anywhere between 30
nucleotides
and 350 nucleotides in length
they could also be different types of
sequencing including single end or
parent
this allows us to increase the accuracy
of the sequence that is captured within
each read as you look at the
pre-processing steps you will see that
there are
a few different options to pre-process
this information after it is processed
and it is ready for analysis
we perform mapping that mapping is
taking the short reads and
aligning them to the reference genome
after those are aligned they have to be
quantified
so that we will be able to analyze the
levels of expression
for different genes
so let's click on ok and you will see
that some
additional steps are becoming available
so for those of you that are following
along now i can connect
the start button with the pre-processing
steps
the only available pre-processing step
at this point
is trim-o-matic trim-o-matic
is a mapping
it is a tool for mapping the reads to a
set
of references that include technical
amplification and library preparation
sequences that will clean up
and reveal only the accurate read
information that will be used for
downstream
alignment and quantification
after you click on ok you can now click
on
pcr clean pcr clean
addresses the issue of bridge pdcr
amplification
which can be biased and can affect
highly expressed genes
after i'm done with the pre-processing
steps i have a couple more
options one option is
to use mapping on genome to identify
different types of alternative splicing
events
or if i'm not interested in alternative
splicing and i'm interested in gene
expression
i can click on bow tie to t which will
map those reads on the transcriptome so
only the express genes that are recorded
in the gtf file
again we will review all of these steps
in greater detail in our next session
and they are also covered in
transcriptomics one
so once i've collected the pre i've
connected the pre-processing steps
with mapping on transcripts i can now
quantify
the gene expression by producing
a table of expression in read count
fpm which is fragment per kilobase per
million or
tpm transcript per million
now the pipeline is complete i can click
on end
and look at the output so here's the
output
these are what's called table of
expression
and table of expression could be for
genes isoforms or
exons and you can also see an example
of a cell line expression data
normalized and annotated
as well as some of the clinical subtypes
included in this particular data set
so this is a quick example of what's
called building a bioinformatics
pipeline
so typically if you are a
bioinformatician you would have to
launch different scripts like pcr
clean or trim-o-matic connect to
different databases
for example trim-o-matic uses a database
of technical sequences
or load in your reference genome
and the annotation file called the gtf
file
to eventually make sure that the file
structure goes from one step to the next
and produces
the final output as well as many
intermediate
steps you will you will discover
very quickly that this is a very
intensive process
that requires high cpu power and
a lot of ram and storage
so for those of you that are going to be
joining the program
we will review in detail how to build
such pipelines
and also look behind the scenes on how
to apply
different types of r packages and python
packages
to perform what's called downstream
analysis
so on the team is platform it is built
for
research tasks that require big data
processing
and high performance computing after the
data is processed
after you have received the table and
you can start
analyzing the data you can turn to
statistical analysis
visualization and machine learning
so what we will do is go through
different types of
pipelines for different types of omics
data and then
extract the data that the pipeline has
produced
to start applying these packages using
coding what's important here is that
biologists and clinicians
are probably not as interested in
developing
proficiency in coding in r in python
but it is important for all of you to
understand
what goes into coding and how coding
packages and libraries are typically
used
to analyze visualize and share the
results
between participants of the wet lab
and the dry lab so we have included a
number of courses
that you will be able to go through
including
analysis of sequencing data integration
of different types of data using
statistical analysis
machine learning different types of data
mining or unsupervised machine learning
and supervised machine learning
and also annotation
so before we move on i want to ask
everyone if you have
any questions about what we cover and
i'll look through the chat to make sure
that i haven't missed anything
okay again i see that there are some
questions about registration
pricing how to register how to access
different resources
i think the best way to do that is to
register for the full program
and we will we will work with you
individually to make sure that you
understand how to access and also
how to leverage some of these resources
in a way
that you learn about bioinformatics and
learn to apply them to your own project
and uh we will definitely be emailing
you
the links uh requirements for your own
computer you don't actually have to have
anything more advanced than a chromebook
if you can download and upload files
that's enough so you can
actually process the data sets on the
cloud
so those are going to be the big data
sets that you process and then you can
use all of the uh different types of
analysis that we're discussing here
on the cloud so you don't actually have
to do any of it on your computer
you will benefit from doing some of it
on your computer so it's beneficial
to have excel or google sheets
and also to be able to upload and
download files so i don't think that an
android
phone is going to be the best option
it's much better to have a laptop
at least at least a chromebook
okay and we've captured all of your
email addresses so those
that have shown an interest
you could actually uh you will receive
an email from marketing at pine bio
cloud processing doesn't need good
internet speed yes good internet speed
and reliable internet speed
is going to be beneficial if you can
join this session and see everything
that we are doing
in this session that means that you
have good internet speed enough for what
we are doing
okay so before we continue
we are going to give you an assignment
the assignment is first of all complete
your profile
on edu that t-bio info so make sure
that not only you register but you put
a profile image you write a little bit
about yourself
maybe add some social media links so
that people can
understand who you are join our social
media groups which we'll talk about in a
second and make sure that your profile
is complete
then you can also explore using this
demo account or if you already
received your full account you can
explore the server.tbioinfo and
code.omixlogic.com some effective
practical tutorials
that we will be doing throughout this
program and please complete the
introduction to bioinformatics course
fill out the survey and try passing the
quiz
so that will give us a good sense of who
you are
and how you are able to apply the
understanding of bioinformatics to
different types of projects
can we run the r scripts in r studio yes
all of the
scripts in the omixlogic coding platform
are downloadable you can just copy them
and open them in our studio and we will
actually be sharing the r scripts with
you
also from the pipeline itself
so now to continue speaking about
projects i see that many of you are
interested in cancer
some of you potentially might be
interested in other types of
projects infectious diseases and others
i want to introduce you
to dr mohit mazumdar is responsible for
partnerships
and is a project mentor in our omixlogic
programs
mohit please take it over
at one second more hits needs to be
okay you you are her host
uh area co-host is me so you have to
make mohit ghost
i did
oh that's you uh one sec
okay thank you and
hello everyone so let me just share
so my name is muhit mazumda and i am one
of the global representatives of pine
biotech
my phd was focused on developing a noble
method for sequence analysis using
machine learning algorithms after
working on
several bioinformatics research projects
i joined bioinformatics industry
where i'm collaborating and working with
the academia
and healthcare industry and the pharma
industry to provide support for
bioinformatics research and
training but it's really exciting to be
to be a part of this omixlogic
experience as a project mentor
and to be able to work on translational
research with a diverse group of
students and
with diverse expertise more often
than not we hear about the biomedical
data being used
being used by pharma industry and
publications from
top research labs so as elia mentioned
there has been a remarkable shift over
the last
decade in the cost of generating uh
molecular measurements
so most impacted by this change in is in
the area of genomic medicine we heard
about
different type of cancers where it is
now possible to move from generating you
know
reference or population level data to
our you know individual level data
so now we we are collecting uh that sort
of information and concurrently
there has been advances in development
of new algorithms and tools
to integrate and interpret this data
which is
what you saw uh the tbi info platform as
an example as well
so if you see this survey this latest
survey you will find out that ai
and big data have the biggest impact on
the pharmaceutical industry however
to understand this application and to be
able to find
information from this big data it's
important to learn
about the analysis strategy and get
experience
working on real data so together with
our collaborators from top universities
we have prepared tutorials for you that
takes you through a project-based
approach
where we take data sets from high impact
publications and use them for practical
exercises recently we finished a few
projects collaborating with students
researchers
and so
recently as i was telling you that we
finished a few projects collaborating
with students
uh so all of these projects and
applications were proposed by the
participants
so here is a picture of
if i don't know if my animation is just
seen or not
so there are a few participants uh for
example
uh anurag who collaborated with our
avra borah and they worked on the
infectious disease project and people
published on different
uh platforms like linkedin and
they got the recognition of that project
being finished and contribution in that
in that research area so for example
here urja parikh recently worked on her
research fellowship
and her project on glioblastoma stem
cells
and uh continued her risk now she's
continuing her research
so um this is a link
let me share this and maybe let's go to
this link
so let me again share
the link
okay so this is the page when you get to
the
project examples which are just which is
being just
shared i guess
so this is where you will find more
relevant examples
um so here we talked about the
guidelines how do we go about a big data
bioinformatics project
after you get the learning and we talk
about uh
pro poster publication or going towards
a
you know full-fledged publication how do
we reach a
place where we have a clear methodology
defined
in terms of abstract methods results and
conclusion
there are some examples that we did
recently in collaboration with lbrn
so you will find those as well and you
will find the abstract and
learn from example so some of the some
of the participants from
uh the infectious disease program and
research fellowship program
collaborated in a group so we uh we want
people
are and this research groups to
collaborate so that they can
you know speed up this process of
working uh on research and different
people have different expertise
so they that helps in uh different
aspects of the project so
this is a such an example so uh after
the project is uh you know finished or
if
it reaches a place where there is more
conclusive uh
information uh the the project is being
recorded as a video so you'll find
videos also where
the the participants are describing the
entire project
and what is the outcome of this project
so here you will see research on scope 2
as a part of infectious disease
research project and then you'll find uh
the research project that i just talked
about about glioblastoma
stem cells and the data available this
was all done through the public
fully available data sets so you will
find them
in different repositories that we
discussed today so there was an
interesting uh you know uh research
proposals that
we were evaluated and worked on
during this entire uh summer and
fall where people dis aware this
our participants and researchers and
faculty
and research labs so we collaborated
with
uh various research labs and faculty
that came up with
their own i and another example
of uh from sarah so
uh sarah zapiko so you saw that uh
the certification as well so this is the
translational aspect of
your learning so please look at the
link and here i mean interestingly the
project based approach or the omics
logic
approach has been taken really well by
undergraduates and high school students
so we have hannah hannah davis here she
is a high school student and finished
her
bioinformatics project working on our
platforms you'll find more
examples from high school students that
those recently joined
our genomics in the virtual lab program
we were able to work on
their own research project on cystic
fibrosis and
uh another example from that program so
you will find
the translational aspect and what is the
outcome one of the outcomes of
these research projects by looking at
some of these examples
so with this uh i think i
i can pass it on to ms beepsha she'll be
able to guide you with
other aspects like program registration
and access to
various resources that we discussed
today thank you everyone
thank you dr mohit pallav if you have
any question
please put them down in the chat box
so that we can look at it and get back
to you
so this is the program registration page
i have already shared the link in the
chats
and i will be posting the link again for
everyone
it's called bioinfomatics.omicslogic.com
so if you scroll down to the site you
will
notice that all the different details of
the
session are added here
and you'll be able to read some reviews
and i'm doing this one more time so that
all those participants who have joined
us for the
first time today are able to complete
the registration
and to complete your registration the
process is very simple you either click
on get started or on pricing either way
this is the thing that pops up
and you can choose between three
options here so the beginner option
will give you access to all of the
resources that were
discussed in this session the
intermediate
membership gives you access to all this
resources
plus a one-on-one mentor support
throughout the length of this one month
program
while the advanced membership gives you
access to the beginner courses
projects armix logic platform and the
t-band for platform
along with mentor support as well as
extra additional
30 more days to work on your project so
that becomes
like a two-month program for you so you
get an not only just one month
another additional month to work on your
project so this you can choose
according to your own preferences and
choices
and for those who are mentioning that
they would want to do projects
please leave any kind of requests that
you have regarding projects
at two marketing at pine.bio and we will
be reaching out to you
with your requests and now
moving on so once you are registered
in this platform so if you scroll down
on this pop-up you'll see that there is
payment details
uh the advanced courses would require
you
to know the basics of biology as well
so we i will be talking about some of
the upcoming advanced
courses uh very soon so just to talk
about the
introduction to bioinformatics program
which we are starting
today the next thing once you complete
your registration what you receive
is your own profile so here i have dr
prashant mishra's profile
he is part of this program so you can
see that he has
a badge which determines that he's part
of this membership
he has been doing some of these courses
and
taking part in the coding platform which
is a code.org logic and he finished
some of the courses here so you see the
points that he has gained
so this is how completed profile looks
like it has a
profile image and a profile name
again you can again contact us marketing
at pine.bio
for any kind of queries related to any
personalized projects
and once you finish your profile the
next thing that you have access to
is the organization page this is the
organization page
exclusively available only to mentors
and you will be able to see details
about the program
see the different syllabuses so
today we are on this first
session on 13th october our next session
will be on 15th october
and also if you scroll down below you
will be able to see all the different
participants who are joining together
with you
and their performance so we can track
everyone's activity
and not only this this organization page
will give you
access to courses that are part of this
program
so as elia was mentioning you should be
completing this is for everybody even if
you're not part of this program
you can complete introduction to
bioinformatics but you also get access
to other premium resources like
transcriptomics one
two then you have introduction to
epigenetics
and more are added as we go along we
also offer
projects as part of this training so
these
projects are available free
to our participants who are part of this
training program again
and these are a synchronous projects
which help you
in your own learning about how to get
started with the bioinformatics project
so these are the other resources that
are available to you
and we have a progress tab to track
everyone's activity so
as we are starting today
we see that the activity is just
starting out
so as we move on we will have more
graphs going around
so in a way we are able to track
anybody's progress and help you
go forward so even though it will be a
group
program program where a lot of people
are joining from different
uh fields of life sciences we are able
to
help each other and guide everyone
throughout this program
using this organization page and our
forum
yes the free courses sedation also come
with
individual certificates so once you
complete a free course it will be
automatically generated not only just
the free courses also all of these
courses will each carry
their own certificates so you not only
earn a complete
program certificate but you also earn
one certificate for doing
each of these courses okay so that is
there
and you can also see the syllabus on
this tab
okay sheetal i will be emailing everyone
the links to the free courses
after this session so that you can uh
look at them
again but again if you are on the edge
of platform you can
just go to introduction to
bi-informatics
and start taking the free course from
here this is the first free course
as elia has been mentioning which is
available for you
and open to everyone so you can take
this introduction to buy informatics
course
thus third thing that you have access to
is the tbio info platform
so this we already had a demo section
about
and every participant will get access to
the educational access to this platform
this platform is also available
as a research tool that can be used by
universities research labs as well and
individual researchers
but for program participants they will
have access to five terabytes of data
in the space in the cloud so and they
will be able to not only work demo
pipelines
but also some pipelines which are shared
and you will also have access to the
code rmx logic platform
now for all of you who may be interested
in advanced courses we have
several of them starting uh in the
coming months
so somebody was interested in breast
cancer and transcriptomics so we have
this transcriptomics course starting
in december we also have a program on
infectious diseases starting on 9th
november
and data science is already ongoing
but it's still open for registration
through this week it has started
yesterday on 12th
october and we also have another program
coming up on metagenomics so this is the
entire list of the programs that are
available for this year for those of you
who are
interested in specific areas which are
not covered
yeah lisa i would like to address some
of the questions that have been coming
up
yes i just wanted to uh
show the research fellowship page just
one moment
you can actually start talking about
this as well
so let's start with uh dr
sheikh sheikh peratt from chennai so
my area of interest is prenatal prenatal
and cancer genetics
i want to i want to i want the details
of ngs data analysis and bioinformatics
application
course so
dr sheikh we would
start this introduction to
bioinformatics course which will
cover uh all of these aspects that you
have
talked about but talking about your area
of interest
is more towards a research project i see
there are
other questions similarly on different
research areas
such as forensic sciences and
nutrigenomics so
once you learn about the application of
the technology you can use it for
all these research areas finding data
sets relevant to
these research areas so the important
thing is is to understand the
application
like transcriptomics how to analyze
transcriptomics data genomics how to
analyze genomics data and what you can
find out of that genomic data
so if you already have a research
question so that
actually helps so you can look for data
sets that
are you know kind of helps in
finding those answers so that is the
kind of data driven research
we are going to do in many of these
programs and that's what
our focus is to simplify bioinformatics
and big data research because
doing this in without the infrastructure
is really
a challenge that we discussed and we
know about
so this platform and entire learning
experience
gives you that opportunity to be able to
work on some of those aspects that you
really want to
using the big data
so there is no certification for this uh
the individual session but you will
get certificates once you finish uh the
asynchronous course that we that we
shared so
uh the asynchronous course or
introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to genomics and
introduction to metagenomics
so these all courses are going to give
you an overview
like uh like the question to the
application of
uh bioinformatics and foreign six
sciences so
uh introduction to bioinformatics please
look at that course and
finish try to finish that course it's a
very simple course and introduction to
genomics gives you a
direction that what is all going on in
genomics what we learn in genomics
and then there is metagenomics so these
are free courses that are available
and that you can gain certificate from
after you finish those courses
so the question to such
to answer so sharply email me
uh yeah email feature the the
research area and the research that you
are interested in
and bioinformatics for neurodegenerative
diseases so we have
uh um we have uh
uh julia panoff she's a new uh
neuroscientist
and a bioinformatician working on
neuroscience
so one of our interns
and few of our interns were working on
neuroscience and data sets associated
with that
and some of them worked on alzheimer's
diseases
so we also have a project on alzheimer's
diseases so
you can work in neurodegenerative
diseases if you register for research
fellowship so that is another program
that is available
for researchers who are pretty much
aware of the census technology
okay santiago we will send you the
details of the research well this is the
research fellowship program yes
thank you so bioinformatics
machine learning prerequisite knowledge
no this is where you can learn
joshua bioinformatics and machine
learning and application
of machine learning in big data
informatics specially
because bioinformatics is a really big
field because of its application from
structural data to you know
genomic data to different kind of data
sets so this is about
ngs data and ngs data you can
learn to apply machine learning with
this uh with this course introductory
course also and
associated material so there's a lot of
asynchronous material that guides you
through
how do you do ngs how do you do apply
uh gene expression machine learning on
gene expression data so
that those all those aspects are very
simplified
and easy to learn through this platform
that's what
i have experienced so yeah
so internships are provided as a
research fellowship program right now
and internships are uh and an advanced
internship is
already uh is only provided for those
who
are expert in our platform so you have
to go through an omics logic platform
and
you have to show that progress
in your research in your learning to be
able to get any
kind of internship long-term internship
or a short-term internship
but the research fellowship program is a
program where you can work on your
project
and you have to take the only take the
license
for the t-bind for platform uh currently
we are supporting the research
uh fellowship program ourselves so
just you have to look get the license
and
the sessions and omit logic training and
everything is included in that
thank you dr mohit for answering the
questions
in the chats yes so everybody who has
left us an individual comment on the
different
areas of uh analysis
and the different research areas that
you are interested in on the different
programs please
wait to hear from us because we will be
individually looking into these requests
and even to sha if you had sent us your
email id
or sent us an email to us or left your
email id in the chat
please wait to hear from us we will be
reaching out to everyone
so that you can do something or take up
any of these courses or do a research
project with us which you are
interested in so thank you again for
joining today's session
saying that if you are joining this
program and the next date
for the second session of this program
is october 15th which is going to be
exclusively available only to our
participants
and you can join via this link
okay deepak we will be sharing the
fellowship link again
personally to everybody via email
so thank you again for joining today so
if there are no more questions
i would like to end today's session
thank you everyone
thank you everyone thank you everyone
okay if you're still leaving your emails
in the chat and if you have left them
before
we have a note of all of your email ids
and your personal requests so we will be
reaching out to you
and you can also request or send us any
information
or an email to marketing at pine.bio
for any other queries you may have
especially if you have a research based
query
or a program query and you would like
more clarification on it
so thank you so much to our speakers
today and to our participants
we'll see you again soon